want to make sure we talk about sarah
cooper everything's fine
of course i'm so glad that that you
are behind this project directing this
is very exciting because
she's obviously this phenomenal talent
she blew
up online i think people are very
excited now that she's got this uh this
project
and it's so cool that you're you're
directing it
yeah i mean i think you know i have this
uh this great production company called
animal pictures
uh with uh with my rudolph uh
i think we sort of felt like what's the
thing to launch this thing and all of a
sudden you know when sarah hit
uh she just felt like the only thing
that was really resonating or connecting
with this moment as far as
a feeling of relief that encapsulated
the sort of uh
you know universal feeling of what the
hell is going on here that she was sort
of providing some sense of relief and
i think the uh goal of the special you
know we never really
um say trump's name in it i think more
so than sort of trying to to comment on
something obvious was uh trying to get
to the heart
of you know this kind of uh social
paranoia and the sort of doom-scrolling
sinking feeling that we all have kind of
in bed as you're slowly melting into it
wondering where this all ends and you
know trying to
you know tap into that through this kind
of network
patty chayefsky sort of as a gag
you know fred holds up a sign as her
producer that's uh
the actual sign from ilya kazan's face
in the crowd you know to show that the
ratings are up
thanks to talking about uh you know uh
sort of shitty politics and and i i just
really think we wanted to kind of
tap into the sort of the the way that we
all feel and sort of
uh sarah has done an extraordinary job
of providing
some relief and some sort of explanation
to this uh
absurdity i mean it is so effing weird
that we are you know that this has
become
some uh degree of normal somehow yeah no
what i really appreciate i appreciate
about what she's done is i love
silly comedy and she's able to be very
physical and silly and
use her abilities to make you laugh and
at the same time acknowledge
how insane everything is right now yeah
i mean
it's very very weird you know and it's a
it's a real curiosity of you know uh
i mean obviously you know i joke but
it's you know uh what is
what is jokes what is time what is a
future what is making plans you know
it's uh it's a very weird
moment that we're in and it's uh it's uh
very um really like levels the playing
ground like we're we're in this
collectively and sort of have to either
uh so anyway you know uh jokes aside i
mean i guess that really is
when i say i'm relieved i i'm just
relieved to see that we're you know
we've
sort of stopped uh lying other than of
course the fake news aspect we've
sort of stopped lying a little bit as a
society which you know hopefully gets to
uh the heart of the truth and maybe we
can
you know begin to build a better world
and so on which is great because i have
so many children and i need to build a
future for them
well you know what i love whenever
you're using your hands in zoom
i feel better about our future so the
more
the kids cone and the kids i'm not even
listening to what you're saying anymore
i'm just seeing
this and i feel liberated and excited
because
you want a flat screen tv i'm going to
get you a flat screen tv just let me
know what kind of
camcorder you need and i'll get it for
you and you're saying that
no one can beat your prices that's i'm
very excited about that
thank you so much we have a clip here
from sarah cooper everything's fine
anything we need to know about this clip
before we show it
uh the duality the gravitas and the
comedy
that comes with the one and only the
living legend that is
helen mirren and now for our top story
an
exclusive look inside that now famous
access hollywood bus
she used to be great she's still very
beautiful i moved on her actually you
know she was down in palm beach i moved
on her and i failed
i'll admit it i did try and she was
married it's huge
sarah oh no nancy no this was just and i
moved on her
very heavily in fact i took her out
furniture shopping
she wanted to get some furniture i said
i'll show you where they have some nice
furniture
i took off her and she i moved on her
like a [ __ ]
but i couldn't get there and she was
married and all of a sudden i see her
she's now got the big phony tits and
everything she's totally changed her
look she's your girl's hottest [ __ ]
the in the purple whoa whoa
yes
and we're back huh that was a great clip
thank you very much uh you know um i
think sarah really wanted to
uh do this one um you know because
it's the one and somehow you know it's
it's crazy that it was
so insane when we first heard it and uh
that it was not the thing that shut it
all down um and we're still here
uh you know i mean just as uh
as a woman it's uh pretty devastating to
uh realize that these are the things
that we're
uh okay with accepting yeah
yeah well um i do think
people say uh laughter is the best
medicine i
like many people disagree medicine's the
best medicine well every viewing of this
special
also comes with a a bottle of
amoxicillin
so you can get it on both sides
okay sarah cooper everything's fine is
now streaming globally on netflix
natasha you are very talented
you're very busy you're always a delight
to talk to
it's not often i get to speak literally
to uh a woman who's time traveled from
1935
with all that moxie and pep and uh
you always brighten my day so thank you
for doing this always a joy conan thank
you so much